for a more in-depth look at all this we
turn to philip bump the national
correspondent for the Washington Post
Philip good morning morning sir so much
to talk about but let's start talking
about what Nancy was reporting on
immigration here as we've heard week the
president says he doesn't like the
children being separated from their
families he calls it horrible he calls
it a Democrats the Democrats law is it
no not at all I mean it's important for
folks to recognize what's happening here
which is that clearly President Trump
doesn't like the political fallout he's
getting from this policy it's broadly
unpopular President Trump himself has
called it a horrible but this is a
policy of his administration and it is a
policy that was designed according to
chief of staff John Kelly and Attorney
General Jeff Sessions as a deterrent the
goal is to scare people away from the
border if you come across the border
we're going to take your children away
that's the intent of it and this is a
policy that is has been implemented by
the administration there is no law that
necessitates it so this is absolutely
something that is his responsibility so
Philip you wrote about this in the
Washington Post but I wonder if you
think that the political pressure that
seems to be mounting over this specific
issue of separation could perhaps be
something that the president and the
administration eventually decides the
longer this goes on the less worth it it
becomes well I think there are two
considerations the first is the politics
and the politics politics of this are
bad when you have the president out
there saying this is a bad thing it's
gonna be hard for him over the long term
could defend it once people become aware
that this is something that he himself
is doing but then secondarily we have a
situation in which the president is is
is taking an action which is not having
the effect that he's intending again
this was meant as a deterrent if you
actually look at the month by month
numbers there's no change in the number
of families in May relative to April
that are approaching the border so it's
not even working as a deterrent which I
think over the long term may be a reason
that he decides to turn away from it
Philip let's turn to Paul Manafort he
spent his first night in jail why did
the judge jail Paul Manafort well
essentially judge jailed Paul Manafort
because she had lost confidence that he
would essentially behave properly well
he was out on bail that he was accused
by special counsel robert muller of a
witness tampering of reaching out to
someone who could testify against him to
try and get their story straight
essentially and so the judge sent him to
jail because she didn't try
said he would she said you know I can't
just take your phone away this isn't
middle school how extreme is this I mean
it's not I wouldn't say it's terribly
extreme if you violate the terms of your
bail then sometimes you have to go to
jail so this is not as president Trump
said because they think he's a big
dangerous mob boss it's cuz he simply
didn't adhere to the rules that he was
supposed to follow at the same time I
mean Paul Manafort is someone who is
accustomed to a certain lifestyle or
wearing $7,000 suit he has an apartment
in Trump Tower so could there perhaps be
pressure on man afford now enhanced
pressure in a way that there wasn't
before that might in fact lead to him
cooperating with the special counsel
well I think that yes I think that
special counsel Muller's not terribly
upset that Paul Manafort has to go to
jail
obviously the special counsel is trying
to put a lot of pressure on mana for
wants him to tell him whatever he
happens to know about President Trump
about the Trump campaign this is
certainly going to be an incentive for
Paul man afford to try and figure out
okay I need to change something I can't
be here very long maybe making a deal is
the way to do it at the same time
according to a CBS news report Michael
Cohen believes that President Trump and
his allies may be turning on him what do
we know about that situation and how
great a threat is going do we think at
this point I mean honestly I think Cohen
is one of the biggest threats to
President Trump and the reason why is
because folks should remember Cohen
started working for the Trump
Organization back in 2007 so he was
there for nine years essentially before
the Trump air campaign got started he
knows all of the deals that Trump was
making he was Trump's so-called fixer he
was a guy sent out to deal with little
messes he knows a lot of stuff he was
there during the campaign he's mentioned
in the infamous steel dossier he
obviously set up the deal with stormy
Daniels the adult film actress there are
all sorts of lots of information that
Michael Cohen has so I'm not surprised
that Donald Trump's getting a little
nervous about it all right Phillip bump
thanks so much for being with us happy
Father's Day Phillip thank you sir